advice from donald trump on finding your  passion as seen in zugo 101  the most important thing in life is to  love what you're doing because that's  the only way you'll ever be really good  at it  money was never a big motivation for me  except as a way to keep score  the real excitement is playing the game  without  passion you don't have energy without  energy you have nothing  it's tangible it's solid it's beautiful  it's artistic  from my standpoint and i just love real  estate other people paint beautifully on  canvas or write wonderful poetry  i like making deals preferably big deals  to learn more check out zugo 101 find  your passion in the link below